I think dr. King's legacy is one of
leadership one of vision one of setting
a standard for how we understand who our
fellow citizens are and who we are as
Americans he spoke to all of those
issues very eloquently when I met dr.
King I was involved in a summer
mentoring program and I was in a
journalism workshop and at that time dr.
King had been named the heir previous he
was named Man of the Year by Time
magazine so everywhere he went to press
followed him so he addressed the people
who were taking part in the program I
was involved in the the mentoring
program he addressed all of the
participants it was about two or three
hundred kids in Harlem and he told them
that their what they were trying to do
to make Harlem a better place by finding
out what was wrong and trying to work on
those issues that was going to be
something that bore really serious fruit
so he spoke to us and then after the
event the press interviewed him and as a
member of the press I they gave me press
credentials and I covered the event like
I was with the press corps so it was you
know the very first person I interviewed
as a journalist was dr. King Wow you
know somebody like that touches your
life in that way it has a profound
effect and it enabled me to get more
behind what he was doing and how he was
doing it because you know there was a
debate going on as to you know was his
approach better or were other more
militant approaches better and really
the answer was that all people who were
concerned about the issues they need to
come together and deal with the issues
and work out all the other stuff later
we found that out the hard way but you
know dr. Caine was a leader in all that
so I think what he means to America is
very profound because we're still
trying to get to the point where we have
achieved all the things that he
envisioned when he said we shall
overcome my most poignant memory of dr.
King would be as he made some of the
points of some of his public speeches
this speech that he gave at the march on
Washington in 1963 is as part of
American history that's part of that is
just as important and just as profound
as the Gettysburg Address
or maybe President Roosevelt addressing
the nation after the attack on Pearl
Harbor I mean those words are etched in
our collective memory in history and our
part of what America is the things that
I learned from dr. King have to do with
perseverance and getting to the point
where you learn how to communicate with
your fellow human beings it's probably
one of the most difficult lessons that
we as humans have tried to absorb and we
keep thinking we have it figured out and
we don't we keep placing ourselves in a
position where we have to work on it and
it requires constant vigilance we get to
the point where all of a sudden we don't
like the people around us and they are
our fellow human beings and in America
they are our fellow citizens how do we
get along it should be a lot easier than
it has proven to be but hopefully we're
making progress
I think dr. King's effect on me
personally was I my ability to identify
goals and understand that it takes a
while to get to the point where you're
satisfied with what you wanted to
achieve with your goals
it's a it takes a while and watching
what he went to in his life and it ended
so tragically but he could see that
maybe America was going to get there
eventually but he didn't live to see it
so there's a lot of disappointment
involved but we can't give up on our
vision and we can't stop working for all
the things that we want to achieve dr.
King changes the trajectory of my life
by giving me a different idea about what
a life well-lived could be again he
achieved so much but the goals that he
identified we didn't get there but just
in pointing those out and helping
America identify the best way to make
our republic grow and become stronger
and one nation I think he gave us some
tools to to get there dr. King was able
to galvanize America because America saw
eventually that what he wanted was just
that black Americans did deserve
first-class citizenship it's it should
not be a difficult thing for people to
get that but it took all of his hard
work and sacrifice including dying the
way he did for America to get the
message dr. King's message has resonated
for so long it is because as Americans
it's something that we all aspire to
it's very noble it's what every country
should aspire to but as Americans we've
gotten the closest to that ideal the
whole idea of every individual being
worthy and every individual having the
right to a vote and to have his or her
opinion recorded and that justifying
their citizenship that that should be
the common experience for all people in
all nations but I think in America we've
come closest to really making it a
reality there for personal
it actually happens here Martin Luther
King jr. day sometimes allows us to pat
ourselves on the back for what has been
achieved and it allows us to ignore the
work that we have to do to get to the
real goals of first-class citizenship
for all Americans we haven't gotten
there yet
there are obvious indications that we
haven't so you know that's why I'm
critical of Martin Luther King jr. Day
because the fact that we have a holiday
does not mean that we have achieved all
of the necessary objectives of dr.
King's life work dr. King's objectives
for where America should go he was
talking about economic equality
something that we need to really be
careful about because the wealth
disparity between those who have and
those who do not have us becoming more
dramatic as time goes on us that's not a
good thing we should protect and allow
our middle class to grow that has been
the best path for our country since its
inception and I think we're getting away
from that so you know I think the
ongoing emphasis on diversity and
equality is a worthy thing for our
country and I hope we stick to it
complacency um uh you know within the
people the community that admires dr.
King they think that everything's swell
everything is not swell but that kind of
complacency is dangerous you know it's
something that allows us to let bad
things continue to fester and that's not
a good thing as far as where we are in
the art of justice because at different
perspectives people can see different
things so people who have done well and
have benefited from modern society I
would say that they see it in a lot more
positive light than people who are
struggling you know I think we still
have work to do with regard to you know
equality and equal opportunity for every
American the whole disparity in
educational opportunities and successes
you know really affects that my dream
for the next 50 years is that Americans
continue to educate the youngest among
us in more effective and you know
intuitive ways you know the whole idea
of you know how to educate young people
really is what gives us the next
generation of knowledge and innovation
and hopefully progress our educational
system really needs to keep pace with
the what's possible in terms of you know
doing a better job of educating the
youngest of others young people really
need to understand the context that dr.
King had to deal with just what America
was about as the second world war ended
and black Americans had this new
consciousness about combating racism
after seeing what happened in the effort
to eliminate fascism you know world war
two and we had the same problems here in
America you know a segment of our
population was being discriminated
against in the same way that Jews and
other minorities were discriminated
against in Nazi Germany and black
Americans saw the correlation of
everything and decided that they needed
to risk risk at all but
we needed to move forward and achieve
our own liberation and I think dr. King
was the ideal person to to lead that
movement and you know the people that
inspired him
Vernon Johns who was dr. King's mentor
those people really are still in the
shadows but they were also visionaries
and help dr. King form his vision and I
think that you know as we go forward we
should learn a little bit about that
whole context you know the people who
helped get dr. King's movement up and
running Americans can honor dr. King's
legacy by just having an honest look in
the mirror as to what we can all do to
[Music]
not give racism and bigotry the
opportunity to get a foothold on on our
public psyche on our institutions and
stuff we really need to eliminate that
it's it's a poison and it can ruin our
society some people think that just
because the poorest among us are the
ones who are the ones that suffer and
you know and that's okay it's not okay
and the ills that they have to deal with
will end up being a problem for all of
all Americans and you know in every
segment of society so I think you know
our own efforts that self-preservation
should also be part of our concern and
we need to survive as the righteous
place that our founding fathers
envisioned I had heard a lot about the
monument to dr. King in Washington DC
but you know it's kind of hard to
imagine it even from the photographs
that you might see of it beforehand but
it's magnificent you know because it
shows them just to me he is a colossus
you know in terms of what he stood for
and the moral
certainty of his vision at all it's all
there you know and just very very well
stated I think it's a it's a beautiful
Monument and people should appreciate it